Transcription: Mohand Habchi
Relecteur: eric vautier
En déposant dans le procès Akayesu,
des témoins ont commencé à relater
des faits de viols multiples.
Même si l'acte d'accusation initiale
n'incluait pas de chef de viol,
il est devenu évident pour la Chambre
que des violences systématiques
avaient été infligées
et qu'elles ne pouvaient être ignorées.
« J'étais avec ma fille
qu'on avait violée... »
« Quand a-t-elle été violée ? »
« Ils l'ont violée
quand ils ont tué mon père. »
« Combien d'hommes
ont violé votre fille ? »
« Trois hommes. »
« Est-ce que cette question vous a été
posée par les enquêteurs du tribunal ? »
« Non, ils ne m'ont pas
posé cette question. »
« Quel âge avait votre fille ? »
« Elle était âgée de six ans. »
En temps de guerre,
le viol est une arme à part entière.
Une arme d'humiliation,
une arme de destruction,
mais avant tout, un objet
de torture et d'emprise sur l'autre.
« Rien de nouveau », me direz-vous,
« on viole depuis la nuit des temps
dans les guerres. »
Mais ce qui est nouveau,
c'est le caractère exponentiel
du nombre des viols
devenus armes systématiques
dans les conflits d'aujourd'hui.
Au moment où je vous parle,
on viole en masse
dans plus de quinze pays dans le monde.
Des millions de vies
de personnes concernées,
impossible à chiffrer.
Parmi ces victimes,
des femmes, des jeunes filles,
mais aussi des hommes
et de jeunes garçons.
Le viol est une arme de guerre,
parce qu'il a un objectif
précis, calculé, planifié.
Ce peut être celui du nettoyage ethnique.
En Bosnie, où j'ai travaillé
pendant des années,
des camps de viol ont été mis en place
pour humilier les femmes,
mais pour les violer aussi
dans le but de purifier la race
et les mettre enceintes d'enfants serbes.
Au Rwanda, le viol a été
un élément constitutif
et un outil du nettoyage
ethnique et du génocide,
reconnu comme tel
par le Tribunal Pénal International,
tardivement.
Plus surprenant,
le viol comme arme de guerre
peut avoir un objectif
économique et territorial.
Au Congo,
dans la région du Kivu,
les bandes armées violent,
tirent dans les vagins des femmes,
enfoncent des pieux
dans le but de détruire entièrement
et définitivement l'appareil génital.
Pour que vous compreniez bien,
en juin, j'étais à Londres
avec Denis Mukwege,
chirurgien congolais,
qui me parle de ce bébé
âgé de trois mois, violé,
amené dans son hôpital à Panzi.
Denis a réussi
à sauver cette petite fille,
mais elle n'aura jamais d'enfants
ni même de rapports sexuels.
Pourquoi cette horreur ?
Parce que détruire la fertilité,
détruire l'appareil génital,
c'est détruire
le trésor national du Congo,
la fierté, le sens d’existence des femmes.
C'est donc détruire le tissu social,
et indirectement, on atteint
les maris, les pères, les frères.
Conséquence :
les militaires et les bandes armées
exploitent illicitement
les zones de minerais,
extrêmement riches et nombreuses
dans cette région.
Le viol comme arme de guerre,
ce peut être aussi
une arme de stratégie politique.
En Libye,
le colonel Kadhafi violait lui-même
les femmes de ses ministres
et de ses chefs de cabinet.
On sait aujourd'hui
que le colonel Kadhafi
avait mis en place un harem.
II choisissait lui-même des jeunes filles
à peine âgées de dix ans
qu'il gardait dans sa maison à Tripoli,
et des jeunes hommes.
Pendant la révolution libyenne,
le colonel Kadhafi a utilisé le viol
comme arme de terreur
à l'encontre des révolutionnaires.
C'est ce qu'il se passe
aujourd'hui en Syrie.
Dans ces deux cas,
on estime que 30 %
des victimes sont des hommes.
Comme le fils d'Hussein
âgé d'à peine 18 ans,
retrouvé dans une villa à Tripoli,
violé, un tuyau enfoncé dans l'anus
comme le répète, incrédule, son père.
« Comment mettre
des mots sur cela ? » me dit-il.
Alors, vous voyez que
le viol comme arme de guerre,
il ne peut pas et ne doit pas
être comparé au viol classique,
crime en soi déjà
monstrueusement dévastateur.
C'est bien une arme à moindre coût,
silencieuse et très efficace.
On me parle souvent
d’assouvissement sexuel
ou de dommage collatéral de guerre.
C'est une erreur fondamentale.
De plus, le viol comme arme de guerre,
il touche non seulement la victime
mais il atteint la communauté, sa famille,
le groupe auquel elle appartient,
politique, social, religieux.
Les blessures, physiques,
psychologiques et sociales perdurent.
Le viol comme arme de guerre,
c'est une bombe
à déflagration lente et multiple.
Les victimes sont totalement
traumatisées, terrorisées.
Comment raconter cette horreur ?
Et quand elles parviennent à le faire,
quand elles veulent briser ce tabou,
la plupart du temps,
les procès ne viennent pas,
et quand ils viennent,
deux sur trois débouchent
sur des acquittements.
Le 21 novembre 2013 au Congo
s'ouvrait le procès Minova.
30 militaires inculpés pour
meurtre, pillage et aussi viol.
135 cas de viol répertoriés,
bien plus en réalité.
Ce procès est une petite
victoire pour les victimes.
Le 5 mai 2014,
les gradés, 13 officiers, sont acquittés,
quelques soldats sont condamnés
pour meurtre et pillage,
et seulement deux pour les viols.
« Pourquoi ? » allez-vous me dire.
Parce que recueillir une preuve
et les éléments judiciaires
pour que les procès
débouchent sur des condamnations,
demandent du temps, de l'expertise
et une présence sur place,
parce que ces victimes
sont totalement terrorisées, traumatisées.
Parce que la plupart de ces pays
sont en conflit
ou en situation post-conflit.
Ce qui veut dire quoi ?
Les institutions ne fonctionnent pas,
mais surtout,
quand elles veulent rapporter
ces viols, à qui le font-elles ?
La police, les institutions ?
qui sont eux-mêmes, la plupart du temps,
les personnes qui violent
ou qui ordonnent ces viols.
Quant aux juridictions
pénales internationales,
pour lesquelles j'ai travaillé,
elles ont reconnu le viol
comme arme de guerre,
comme élément constitutif
d'un crime contre l'humanité
et même d'un génocide.
C'est un grand pas en avant,
mais elles peinent encore
à l'intégrer dans les chefs d'accusation.
Par manque de preuves,
mais aussi parce qu'elles
posent des priorités ailleurs.
Le viol comme arme de guerre,
c'est le crime parfait.
Alors, certains d'entre vous
en ce moment dans la salle
sont peut-être en train de se dire :
« Tout ce qu'elle nous raconte
c'est horrible,
et qu'est-ce que nous pouvons faire ?
Est-ce qu'on ne peut pas démonter
la mécanique d'un crime parfait ?
Et puis, pourquoi s'intéresser
au viol comme arme de guerre,
aujourd'hui, maintenant ?
Pourquoi cela serait
plus important qu'autre chose,
avec tout ce qu'il se passe
dans le monde ? »
On peut légitimement se poser la question.
Parce que si vous aviez
rencontré un de ces survivants,
comme ils s'appellent eux-mêmes,
vous auriez la réponse.
Parce que nombre d'entre eux
disent qu'ils auraient préféré
mourir plutôt que de vivre cela.
Parce que si vous aviez
rencontré Alma, 27 ans,
opposante syrienne,
violée tellement de fois,
qu'elle ne peut se souvenir
du nombre de fois,
vous auriez la réponse.
Les victimes ont en assez
des mots, elles veulent des actes,
et la compassion ne suffit pas,
et il y a des solutions sur le terrain,
elles sont simples.
Médicalement, il faut assister, réparer
comme le fait Denis Mukwege au Congo.
Il faut soigner le trauma.
Juridiquement, il faut
aider les gouvernements
à localiser, traquer les auteurs de crime,
prendre les lois nécessaires
et adaptées à leur propre pays.
Je l'ai fait en Bosnie.
Je veux le faire aujourd'hui en Libye
avec le ministre de la Justice libyen,
un homme extraordinaire,
monsieur Margani,
qui appelle les victimes de viol
en Libye,
les perles de la Libye.
Faire changer la honte de camp.
Cet homme a émis un décret
reconnaissant les viols massifs
en Libye et créant une commission.
Et puis il faut une approche
holistique, sur le terrain.
Continuer à travailler
avec les institutions
mais aussi surtout avec les victimes,
parce qu'elles, mieux que personne,
savent ce dont elles ont besoin
et comment.
Alors moi, je continue
mon métier de juriste internationale,
mais cette année, j'ai eu
envie d'aller plus loin.
Avec Nathalie Wormser
qui est avec nous
dans la salle aujourd'hui,
on a créé une ONG qui s'appelle
« We Are Not Weapons of War »
- « Nous ne sommes pas
des armes de guerre ».
Parce que je suis fatiguée
d'entendre que ces choses-là arrivent.
Fatiguée d'entendre
qu'il n'y a pas d'argent pour des projets.
Parce qu'aussi, la première des choses,
c'est informer, savoir de quoi on parle.
Et informer, c'est agir.
C'est déjà passer de l'idée à l'action.
Alors nous commençons
par lancer une campagne simple
à laquelle tout le monde peut s'associer.
Vous avez une arme.
Cette arme, c'est celle
de votre engagement.
C'est celle de votre non-indifférence.
C'est celle qui vous permet
de décider ce qui acceptable
et ce qu'il ne l'est pas.
Moi, je ne suis pas une arme de guerre.
Et vous ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)